yes I believe it's very possible for
India become a superpower it's a tough
trajectory but I think you have a lot of
advantages number one you have a
population to them people coming up
which everybody knows is going to be the
heart of the energy of the country and
of innovation in the country if you
manage this upcoming population and
manage to channel those energies
appropriately into innovation
entrepreneurship etc and you create the
structures the innovation frameworks
that can allow this to be sustainable
then I think you have a very realistic
shot of becoming one of the world
superpowers you're already on the way
with a phenomenal growth rate but that's
not enough you need to create a lot of
other systems and infrastructures around
this that are been enabled this growth
rate to be sustainable in a way that the
super powers have been able to do for
themselves such as the United States and
previously although failed the Soviet
Union I think probably the model is one
that's more based on innovation science
and technology base innovation I think
is particularly important and channeling
the energy of your youth which you're
going to have a phenomenal advantage